trapped and desperate one of dozens of
people trying to escape the fire in a
casino he uses bed sheets to try and
drop to safety
emergency teams attempt to reach more
people inside
the ties
to Ritual workers they are working
around the clock to rescue those people
who apparently trap on the 18th floor
they believe that at least
another 53 of them were lost and died I
mean die and still alive among the 53
and also the Cambodian senior official
Deputy Prime Minister over there
provincial Governor over there local
police were there they're trying to sort
of are waiting to see if there are any
people on the 18th floor were still
alive and also still I don't know how
many more were trapped there yeah Hong
Kong the fire started late on Wednesday
night and continued to burn into the
morning
it took hours to get under control an
electrical fault is being blamed for
sparking the flames
the grand diamond City Casino employs
about 400 people many from Thailand
firefighters and ambulance Crews from
that country took part in the rescue
efforts
although gambling is illegal in Cambodia
and most forms abandoned Thailand many
hotel casinos operate along the border
between the two countries
concerns have long been raised over the
Region's lacks health and safety
regulations
Barbara angerpa Al Jazeera